the big one
those three words make locals along the
west coast of north america
shudder with fear this area
is plagued by earthquakes but hey
at least they are ready
unlike the middle of the continent which
is woefully unprepared for the event
that physically rips the united states
in half
[Music]
what could cause this
[Music]
what would the destruction look like
and would the united states become
two separate countries
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if america were split apart
mega thrust earthquakes are the largest
and
deadliest seismic events on earth
they occur along fault lines where the
edge of one plate
is forced downward into the hot mantle
beneath another plate
the cascadia subduction zone along the
west coast of north america
last caused a megathrust earthquake on
january 26th
in the year 1700
and many people claim that it's overdue
for another one
the cascadia subduction zone is created
by the juan de fuca
oceanic plate which is moving down into
the mantle of the north american plate
it's not a smooth movement though and
pressure builds as the plates lock
together
and builds and builds
until the north american plate suddenly
pops
on top of the older juan de fuca plate
this would trigger a mega thrust
earthquake
decimating the western coastline of the
united states but
that's not all somehow
the force of this terrifying earthquake
causes the thinnest part of the tectonic
plate
between california and colorado to snap
this is now an end of days nightmare
scenario
a crack races from california all across
the united states
splitting the nation in two
this deafening event would cause roads
to crumble
houses to fall into the giant crevice
and
many deaths
water from the pacific and atlantic
oceans would rush
in to fill the void causing three meter
high tsunamis
and flooding along the midline of the
united states
roads power lines and sewer pipes would
tear apart
pipelines carrying crude oil would burst
adding toxic oil to the massive floods
it would take a national effort to clean
up and
rebuild both the coastline and middle
america
[Music]
hopefully it would bring the country
together
and after all the rubble is cleared
we would begin to assess our new
physically split
nation
the rift would only be about 20 meters
wide
[Music]
you'd be able to wave to your neighbors
from across the divide
the two sides would gradually drift
apart
at about three to five centimeters per
year
[Music]
and the rift would eventually grow and
form a new ocean but for now it's just a
canal
at first you would rely on ferries to
shuttle people
cars and supplies between the two halves
eventually we would engineer segmented
bridges that could be elongated as the
rift grows
the canal itself would be used as a
quicker shipping route between the west
coast and europe
middle america would develop shipping
ports waterfronts and beaches which
would attract tourists and new residents
the new middle coastline would explode
in population with
large cities growing along this new
transportation route
the united states would likely stay a
single nation
for a while it just went through a
shared tragic event and
the rift is only 20 meters wide after
all but
as the newly separated plates began to
move farther away
differences in culture and politics
could increase
and the possibilities of the two sides
politically splitting up would look
more inevitable after
many years of division there could be a
south
united states and north united states
now the probability of the united states
physically breaking in two
is very low to impossible
however in africa it's actually
happening
along the east african rift
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you